be a tough that's going to be a tough score to
beat got to watch Conor on these on the first
uh first two turns here McDavid the odds on
favorite he has reached the top speed of 23.5
mph this season his average speed this is where
he excels look at that this just looks different
look at his feet never stop moving never stop
looks different never stop moving well there's
winner winner chicken parm dinner the ability
for him to hold the edges in the corners at
top speed is what separates him from most of
the players of the National Hockey League and
that was on full display right there he grew up
in the Toronto area he did Nick a couple pylons
mess but those things are light didn't affect
him at all didn't affect him fourth win in this
competition most all time he can uh like I said
if he puts his if he puts his heart into it and
he really goes for it I don't think there's
a faster scared in the National Hockey League
and this is why right here watching his Fe
through the corners but being able to hold
the edge at top speed a lot of strength a lot
of skill a lot of practice but Nobody Does it
Better that's going to be a tough time to beat
so there's six primary events in round one the
player picks which four he wants to go in aror
McDavid a lot of his summer work is doing this
drill right here so this could be an advantage for
him because this is what he trains on this is one
of his suggestions to the NHL when the two sides
got together to try to make this skill competition
a little better for the fans create some drama
some nervousness maybe for the players cuz they're
playing for 1 million bucks no one does this
better than look look at the speed he does it
with now he's going toel quickly oh little stumble
on the edge there you can see the you can see
the transition is not quite as smooth as as as a
defenseman right but still not too bad I thought
K Mar would do this one as well try going to beat
Hughes oh my goodness [Applause] unbelievable the
acceleration is just insane he is clearly taking
this seriously oh like he does everything he
wants to win this I more than anybody out there I
believe there's a little stumble on the left skate
[Applause] there and then just make sure
you get the job done there and finish the
guys under the cut have to really pour it on
McDavid wants to continue getting points he
wants the overall Championship one for one
two for two three for three can he do it yes
oh tremendous oh and quick and to see the the
way he shot it with some velocity 9158 the new
leader all right mes you said go low
first he actually went an order he did
he went he went around the clock yeah went
around the world boom really like the way
he attack your target so remember he
already has two first tonight that's
one of the tie Breakers later is how many
first you get if you're tied with a guy in
total points so he talks to kale Mar there
live scoring eight points gets McDavid the
[Music] win I guarantee he's got a little
adrenaline run right now BCI but competitive
as he is so here it is getting crowned he's
got to beat Matthew 47.2 that's his time
we've been debating it but now we're going
to find out well a lot of people called this
the Conor McDavid Invitational if there was no
salary cap the range be paying him 50 million
so this is way a way to get Conor an extra
million bucks let's see I think he wants a
win 47 seconds for a million dollars that's
a good start oh just misses the this is the
narrow one this is the hardest one he got
it now this is an easy one for him that's
a piece of cake he's going to do it just don't
fall down Conor you're going to win a million
dollars don't fall down Connor and put the biscuit
in the basket $1 million shot here it is oh no
problem what a performance what a performance
by what we thought was the best player in the
National Hockey League avilable maybe for some but
now we know BCI incredible incredible I love the
compet $1 million to Conor McDavid the man will
help re imagine the event bring some
juice some drama mission accomplished
what the professionalism though
the compete that he's shown just
incredible a little rough
through the stick handling
portion barzal was probably ahead of him at
this point but McDavid got the first net and
then finished off no problem just had to finish
it off here that was a that's unbelievable what
a performance I'm here with with Conor McDavid
Connor I'm sitting on the bench with JT Miller
and JT looks at you and he looks at me and week
see he goes one run for a million dollars and it
seems like every single time you're on the ice
you're faced with the pressure the adversity to
step up put your team on your back represent
your city you do it how does it feel to be a
millionaire now and how do you do it every
time yeah you know obviously there's money
on the line and it's fun um no special to go
up against all these guys here 12 12 of the
best hockey players in the world and um like I
said we were here to put on a show and I hope
the fans enjoyed it um I know I did well you're
a consumate professional and you know what for a
lot of kids there's a lot of kids watching you're
a great example Conor McDavid best player in the
world right now folks shows it again today shout
out to Edmonton Oilers thanks Conor appreciate
that there we go Conor McDavid 16 wins in
a row currently they'll go for their 17th
in a row on ESPN plus Tuesday then he wins
his skills competition it's pretty good to
be Conor McDavid Conor McDavid came in here he
was an instrumental in changing the format had
a big say in it and then came out here and
delivered it was just incredible to watch
what a performance by him and showed why he's
the best player in the in the National Hockey
League and of course the best player in the
world getting the big check from Bill Daly
$1 million now next on his agenda win a Stanley
Cup that's what uh he's going to be putting all
his focus in win a Stanley Cup and uh I'm sure
at some point in his career he's going to do it